les propos de camélia jordana font
polémique depuis 48 heures hashtag a
même vu le jour sur les réseaux sociaux
à stein je ne me sens pas en sécurité
face à un flux d'où notre question ce
soir les français ont-ils peur de la
police c'est l'objet de notre face à
face ce soir et pour en débattre nous
sommes toujours en direct par sky avait
skype avec david guiraud porte-parole
jeunesse la france insoumise bonsoir
david guiraud merci d'être avec nous à
ses côtés pour en débattre
olivier reverdy secrétaire national
adjoint alliance police bonsoir à vous
merci également à tête avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors david olivier
reverdy notre syndicat a appelé
christophe castaner à saisir la justice
après les propos de camélia jordana
finalement il annoncé ce soir qu'il
n'allait pas le faire est ce que vous
regrettez
cette décision non alors pour être plus
précis on a appelé deux choses on a
appelé christophe castaner à saisir de
la faire mais d'un autre côté nous avons
aussi saisi le procureur de la
république de paris afin qu'ils exercent
l'opportunité des poursuites qui est de
sa responsabilité
donc aujourd'hui on prend acte des
propos de notre ministre de l'intérieur
de ne pas déposer plainte
on peut le regretter mais en attendant
alliance a quand même saisi le problème
parquet de paris afin qu'ils se
saisissent lui-même de cette affaire
sans sans la volonté de notre ministre
avant de donner la parole évidemment à
david guiraud c'était important pour
vous justement de saisir le procureur de
la république pour quelles raisons bien
évidemment c'est important parce que ces
propos sont inacceptables et on aurait
aimé que madame jordana fasse parler
d'elle par son talent plutôt par ses
propos haineux encore une fois
stigmatisé la police comme elle le fait
d'un climat qui est le nôtre aujourd'hui
quand elle parle de massacre c'est
quelque chose d'extrêmement fort et
c'est certainement pas la réalité la
réalité de ce qui se passe en france est
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que les tensions
qu'il peut y avoir dans notre société
dans les policiers mais aussi les
pompiers mais aussi tout ce qui
représente l'ordre dans ce pays est
toujours
ga débat et à attention et violence
ultra violence on voyait des guets-apens
régulièrement il ya des rodéos sauvages
il ya des policiers qui lorsqu'ils
quittent leurs services se font suivre
par des individus jusque vers leur
domicile de manière à exercer des
violences et des intimidations
vous avez on l'a vu tout ce qui s'est
passé depuis de nombreuses années donc
il s'agit pas aujourd'hui de jeter
l'opprobre sur l'ensemble des policiers
mais c'est pour ça que ces propos sont
inacceptables et on les condamne et on
demande à ce que le procureur de la
république de paris en face d'eux mêmes
david guiraud donc à sanair christophe
castaner qui ne saisit pas la justice
mais le procureur de la république lui
etc et vous comprenez quand même la
colère de david olivier reverdy et son
besoin justement de saisir les autorités
non je pourrais la limite entendre ce
que pourrait dire un policier l'entamé
en s'agissant d'alliance police pardon
mais vous avez des indignations
sélectives
regardez par exemple si vous ne vouliez
pas que le débat public soit attisé
regarder ça c'est un journaliste vous
voyez vous avez fait une affiche sur un
journaliste vous le comparez un chien
voilà ça c'est alliance police a donc je
sais pas comment vous envisagez vous le
débat public moi je pense qu'il faut
avoir une position que constantes ou
bien on veut régler les choses
pacifiquement par le débat c'est
d'ailleurs ce que propose camélia
jordana ou bien on joue sur deux
tableaux comme vous faites et moi je
trouve ça pas pas très sérieux
camélia jordana elle le dit avec ses
mots c'est des mots forts c'est vrai
mais vous savez c'est l'article 15 de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et 10
et du citoyen de 1789 qui dit la société
a le droit de demander compte à tout
agent public de son administration et
donc de jeu camélia jordana estime
qu'elle est dans une situation que le
pays dans une situation qui n'est pas
normale et elle demande des comptes à un
corps de la fonction publique et la
police nationale qui aujourd'hui se
dévoie parfois dans certaines opérations
de police évidemment pas du tout
d'ailleurs
david guiraud je me permets de vous
couper mais effectivement le monde
massacré ce que accrue du personnel tout
même vous trouvez que il n'y est pas
allé un petit peu fort
camélia jordana c'est quand même pas
rien d'évoquer un massacre non c'est pas
rien mais vous savez je pense que c'est
à la hauteur
son ressenti en vérité ces mots c'est
pas les miens mais c'est ses mots et
j'ai envie d'un héros gay condamné ce
que je trouve ce que je trouve étonnant
quand même dans cette histoire si vous
avez une citoyenne qui vous fait part de
son malaise qui vous le fait part de
manière honnête de son malaise vis-à-vis
de la police nationale qui dit il ya un
problème et qui se retrouve notamment de
la faute d'un syndicat de police
au box des accusés c'est ça qui n'est
pas normal je vous le dis et je vous le
redis
si on veut que la situation se dénoue il
faut qu'ils aient un débat on peut pas
mettre une chape de plomb sur
l'imposition sur les débats de cette
manière là on a le droit de demander des
comptes à la police nationale sur la
manière dont elle fonctionne et camélia
jordana est quelqu'un qui est engagée
elle se bat notamment dans le collectif
pour justice et vérité pour adama traoré
ce sont des collectifs dans lesquels on
a connu des morts suite à des
interventions et à des opérations de
police et parfois les familles par
exemple je prends le cas de ma famille
this is a tramp 2011 sept ans plus tard
sa famille ne sait toujours pas comment
il est mort voyez je vous parle de
situations concrètes la papa de la
théorie un peu fumeuse de situations
concrètes que vous avez des gens qui ne
savent pas pourquoi les proches leurs
proches sont décédés à la suite d'une
opération de police
si on ne peut pas dire que c'est pas
normal alors on ne peut plus rien dire
dans le pays mais dans ce cas là on
n'est plus dans une démocratie on est
dans un autre régime c'est autre chose
ou c'est la police qui n'assume plus ce
rôle je dis et je finis sur ça le rôle
de la police
c'est d'amener des citoyens qui ont
promis qu'ils ont commis un crime ou un
délit parfois c'est de les amener vers
les tribunaux d'accord si en cours de
route il y à un mort c'est que
l'opération de police ne s'est pas bien
passé alors parfois il ya des
résistances
si un policier se retrouve en face de
quelqu'un qui la grèce au pistolet et
qu'il tirait alors qu'il est à un mètre
c'est compréhensible mais par contre
quand vous avez des gens qui parce
qu'ils courent ils courent se retrouvent
décédé à la suite d'une opération de
police dans un fourgon de police
bah je suis désolé ce n'est pas normal
moi j'assume de dire que je veux que ma
police soit républicaine et qu'elles
soient au meilleur niveau d'excellence
et d'exemplarité pour le pays non mais
je pense que le monsieur guy roux se
trompe de débat pour toutes les affaires
dont il a cité il ya les la justice qui
est saisie et des enquêtes judiciaires
qui seront en cours eni messieurs
guiraud ni madame jordana ne sont là
pour faire la justice dans ce pays
donc soit on est républicain et on est
juste
bout et dans ces cas là on fait
confiance aux enquêtes judiciaires comme
nous nous le faisons parce que lorsque
des policiers foot et sachez qu'ils sont
qu'ils sont tous très rapidement et
administrativement sanctionné que la
justice est aussi passent aussi chez
nous et que nous pouvons être aussi
condamné au même titre que n'importe qui
donc là aussi il ne faut pas faire
justice à travers des média des médias
interposés
la justice est saisie pour les affaires
dont vous avez parlé j'ai à faire et va
ouvrir d'autres affaires la justice est
saisie laissez la travailler nous en
attendant on revient sur l'actualité qui
nous concerne les propos de madame
jordana sont inqualifiables sont
inqualifiables parce que il déjà on
parle de massacre dont très bien au delà
du mot mais ce mot quand même
relativement important même extrêmement
important et choquant mais au-delà de ça
les propos qui englobe l'ensemble d'une
corporation l'ensemble d'une corporation
sont tout à fait inacceptables tout à
fait inacceptable aujourd'hui et madame
jordana met de l'huile sur le feu parce
qu'on sait que le climat social est
tendu
le climat social est extrêmement tendue
et qu'aujourd'hui
madame jordana se permet il se permet de
justement d'attiser et de mettre de
l'essence sur des braises vous demandez
jamais pourquoi le climat est tendu
vous dites pas que c'est peut-être parce
que par exemple à une étude en 2009 1,7
et le cnrs qui l'a menée aux abords
d'une gare parisienne les individus qui
sont perçues comme noir il subit six
fois plus de contrôles que ceux perçus
comme blanc que les individus perçu
comme arabe
ils ont huit fois plus de chances d'être
contrôlés que les individus perçu comme
l'eau vous croyez que la colère sociale
vient de nulle part est évidemment dans
une situation d'injustice parce qu'il ya
des injustices
ce n'est pas que la police qui l'a créé
d'ailleurs il ya des injustices sociales
mais quand il ya une injustice les gens
ne se laissent pas faire les gens qui se
noient ils se débattent et donc il ya
des résistances c'est pour ça que cette
situation n'est même pas bénéfique pour
les policiers
et c'est pour ça que moi je déplore le
fait que votre position ça soit à dire
en vérité qu'il faut papier de départ je
pense qu'un débat ça pourrait aussi
aider les policiers dans leurs
conditions de travail
parce que quand les gens ont confiance
dans la police ils coopèrent quand ils
ont peur de la police ils ne coopèrent
pas c'est quelque chose qui me semble
simple a rappelé et je rappelle que la
cour de cassation a jugé en 2007 que les
contrôles discriminatoires constituer
une faute lourde commise par l'état
c'est donc
un problème est que même la justice dont
vous parlez le reconnaît et que quand il
ya un problème et que ça n'est pas
résolu par des pratiques conformes à la
dignité des gens bah oui il ya des
résistances que je déplore derrière ce
canton parfois métier je voulais avoir
vous faire poursuivre ce débat je vais
vous montrer quelques chiffres les
résultats d'un sondage ifop paru en
janvier 2020 regarder ce thème qui va
s'afficher à la question que vous
inspire spontanément la police de la
confiance pour seulement 43% des
français contre 53 % il ya vingt ans une
chute donc considérable l'inquiétude est
un sentiment qui gagne également nos
concitoyens en passe de 14 à 20 % en
vingt ans david olivier reverdy
est ce que ces chiffres il vous
interroge justement entre vous ont parlé
entre vous entre collègues il ya une
grande incompréhension finalement un
grand malentendu comment vous vous le
l'expliqué dans l'histoire en fait c'est
que aujourd'hui on voit la société est
de plus en plus tendues et de plus en
plus difficile d'un point de vue social
d'un point de vue économique est
aujourd'hui une certaine partie de la
population refuse l'ordre de la
république refuse d'appliquer les lois
de la république aujourd'hui nous sommes
là nous sommes une police républicaine
n'en déplaise à madame jordana nous
sommes une police républicaine
lorsqu'il s'agissait de gilet jaune que
les gens soient de couleurs soient
français soit de n'importe quelle
origine
c'était pas notre sujet on était là pour
faire respecter la loi et empêcher des
exactions empêcher dû empêcher du mieux
possible de ce qu'on pouvait faire que
des commerces soient cassés que des
individus soit violente et c'était là
aussi notre métier quand on fait du
maintien de l'ordre
ça se fait pas avec des roses et des
pâquerettes le maintien de l'ordre
aussi quand on a des gens qui sont
arrivés de boules de pétanque de
cocktails molotov d'acide d'acide
chlorhydrique parce que mes collègues
ont reçu des jets d'acide chlorhydrique
des bouteilles d'acide chlorhydrique oui
monsieur guy roux c'est aussi la réalité
si aussi la réalité qui est la nôtre
aujourd'hui
donc là aussi effectivement si vous
voyez que par le bout de la lorgnette de
certaines violences qui pourraient avoir
lieu
ces violences quand on les prend sur des
vidéos si généralement des morceaux qui
sont pas pris dans leur contexte en là à
l'ensemble et la justice la justice qui
se saisit demande généralement rétablit
le droit rétablit le droit de
l'intervention parce que quand on parle
sachez aussi que la police monsieur guy
roux la police a à l'exercice de la
violence légitime donc de la force
légitime
c'est le code pénal qui nous l'un qui
nous autorise tandis que les violences
illégitimes faites par des citoyens sont
répréhensibles par la loi mais alors
vous pouvez me dire oh oui vous faudra
que vous m'expliquez alors dans ce cas
là qu'est ce qui est légitime quand un
homme comme jérôme rodriguez sans
manifestation puisque vous parlez des
jets les autres qui est un manifestant
totalement pacifique personnalisé
légitime ça est-ce que cet autre homme
vous savez il ya une enquête du monde
qui montre que le tir de balistique
n'était pas approprié qui personnel en
pleine manifestation alors qu'il était
en train de discuter avec ses amis
c'est légitime ça vous voyez moi j'ai
pas une approche purement juridique de
la chose parce que si on fait comme ça
alors la société c'est juste un livre de
droit qu'on lit tous comme une bible
c'est pas ça la vérité il y a dans la
dent dans notre pays ce qui est légitime
et puis ce qui est supportable parce que
ça ce n'est pas normal vous avez des
gens aujourd'hui qui sont placés dans
des situations pas normale dans le pays
quand vous êtes contrôlés beaucoup plus
que les autres parce que vous êtes noir
ou arabe parfois avec des contrôles
discriminatoires parfois même humiliante
parfois même c'est moussa tes papiers
parce que les avants vérité les
policiers connaissent le prénom de la
personne dont on connaît son identité
mais lui faut quand même un contrôle
d'identité
eh bien ça n'est pas normal de la même
manière qu'avec un manifestant quand
vient la nature et 0,44 à perdre sa main
il doit aller peut-être devant les
tribunaux mais le rôle de la police est
de l'amener devant les tribunaux pas de
rendre elle-même justice voyez c'est ça
je pense que vous avez oublié dans la
conception de la police ne rend pas
justice monsieur les tribunaux et deux
pour qu'il fasse peu la justice pas vous
merci messieurs merci d'avoir été avec
moi et d'avoir accepté en tout cas un
débat courtois ce soir après ses propos
chocs de la chanteuse camélia jordana